i'll give you a personal example the
person who's who sold me this property
uh
it was the seller's agent oh okay right
he was charming and nice and wonderful
and lovely and helpful and all the
things that i would expect and i warmed
up to him and he was
apparently helping me and then i
remember
distinctly at the closing
he sat there with no personality all of
his charm had left
all his friendliness had gone he barely
engaged with me he just wanted to be
there to collect his checks he could get
out of there
and
i realized it was all fake
it was all for show it was all to butter
me up so that i would simply sign on the
dotted line and as a result i will never
work with him again as a buyer or a
seller i'll never list with him ever
and i probably will never work with that
company again because i realize they
just saw me as a number they never saw
me as a person in the first place
um he was an old white guy i mean that
should tell you a little bit of
something as well that that sort of
maybe how he was raised in the industry
um and by the way the mortgage broker
was no different
you know uh he was charming and
wonderful and lovely and helped me get a
great rate etc etc and then i remember
after i closed he called me and said
congratulations and i said oh thank you
that's so nice of you he called me just
to congratulate me on closing on my
house and then the first thing he said
to me was and if you know anybody who's
looking for a mortgage i'd really
appreciate the recommendation he never
called me to congratulate me he called
me because he wanted the referral
like give it a breath you know like call
me and congratulate me and a week later
asked me for the referral and see let me
tell you what sucks about that can i say
that what sucks about that totally is
that's
that one person yeah colored your
but
and but this is finite versus infinite
he he could only see the transaction he
could only see get business get more
business get business get more business
what he didn't understand is he's
dealing with a human being and the more
there's a relationship
i will gladly recommend him i will
gladly introduce you to my guy right
now i'm completely agnostic because if
you're going to treat me like a
transaction i'm going to treat you like
a transaction if you're going to treat
me like a transaction i'm going to
squeeze you to get more money out of you
i want a lower rate i'm going to squeeze
the agents but if you treat me like a
human being i'll gladly pay a higher
rate because i want to work with you and
that's what infinite-minded players
understand better which is you don't
have to be the cheapest
you don't have to have the lowest rate
or the lowest price if you have a great
relationship